hello everyone
my brother-in-law son suggested that I
should make an intro while rotating on
my chair so there it is this is this is
a game and this is the second game I'm
already showing on my channel from the
very strong cervix tournament of 1959
and I showed the game where Michael Tao
beats the current Swiss Champion dieter
Keller I mean the current in 1959 and
this is a this is two rounds before the
tournament ended Bobby Fischer is
playing against the Swiss national
champion dieter Keller and from the
beginning of this tournament the Bobby
Fischer has been tied with Michael Tao
for the score and it was known that
Fischer would play tall in the last
round and that Fischer would have the
black pieces and while Fischer was
playing this game with dieter Keller a
towel already defeated his opponent with
a very quick victory so Fisher was well
if he was obligated to win this game to
stay tied with the score would Michael
Tao and well Fischer definitely was the
stronger player but as it usually is
just being the stronger player doesn't
win you the game you also have to play
good moves so let's see this game
Fischer has the white pieces and the
dieter Keller has the black pieces we
have E 4 B Bobby D 5 Knight to f3 Knight
to c6 and Bishop to b5 Bobby goes for
the Royal opus a6 Morphy defense by
Keller Bishop today for Knight to f6
Fischer castles Bishop to e7 rook to e1
and b5 Bishop to b3 b6 C 3 so all
standards Theory Keller castles Bobby
goes for h3 and Knight to d7 and d4 we
have nice to b6 and well here player
Fischer plays D captures on e5 and this
isn't really the best continuation for
white as well
too much exchanges will happen and
official already played 2 games this
year with this variation D captures an E
five and he didn't achieve much from the
opening later some seven years after
this game was played a Fisher play
tonight B to d2 in a game against fresh
chevre ski and this was a much better
continuation but okay Fischer played D
captures on e5 Knight captures on e5
Knight captures on e5 d captures on e5
and Queen to h5 and it seems like a like
an aggressive idea but black is
perfectly fine here Bishop to f6 Knight
to d2 by Fischer Queen to e7 and knights
to f1 Bishop to e6
we have 90 to e3 and now g6 kicking the
Queen away from h5 Queen to f3 and now
grabbing that Bishop on b3 Bishop
capture some b38 capture some b3 and
Bishop to g7 and black is perfectly fine
here we have b4 Fisher doesn't allow
this pawn that is done a6 to move
further as he likes it done on a six and
a light square as well this rock is the
only piece defending it and for now this
rook is stuck on a8 we have c6 and well
here probably it's not that easy to find
to find a good plan for white probably a
move like rook to d1 followed by
developing this dark square Bishop
somehow but Fischer has to go for the
win as I said tal won't already won his
game he's up a full point had a fissure
and well Fischer was for g3 he starts
pushing his King side pawns Queen to e6
attacking h3 and h4 Keller pushes f5 and
Fischer goes for h5 with f4 by Keller
and now Knight to f1g captures on h5
Queen captures on f h5 and rook to f6
and as it usually is when you're pushing
for the win in a in a drawn position
it's usually your opponent that gets the
initiative and it's usually for free so
night 2 h2 by Fischer and now we have
roped to g6
depending that pawn on g3 nice to f3 and
now F capture some g3f capture some g3
rook captures and g3 Fisher gave up on
trying to get any sort of counterplay
maybe maybe game that G file for himself
but it doesn't look like Lee King to h2
by Fisher and now Keller immediately
goes for Queen to g4 he's up upon he
wants to exchange Queens and well he's
definitely not gonna lose this game
Queen theatrics on g4 rook captures and
g4 and well the strongest move in this
position is definitely kink to h3
attacking this rook and the wall either
h5 will be played or maybe moving to
root 2 G 6 but Fischer went for up to g1
and what's the idea
well trading pieces definitely goes into
Keller's favor Fischer was hoping that
Keller will go for this efore pawn as
after rook captures any foreign Bishop
to h6
Fischer is back in the game and this is
well much better for white now but after
rook to G 1 killer of course doesn't
grab the e4 pawn as well he sees the
threat of Bishop h6 and he just
exchanges rook rook captures in g1 king
capture send you one and now Knight to
a4 a brilliant move by Keller as this
nice to a4 move completely immobilizes
Fischer's Queen side and now Fischer
cannot develop this rook as he can't
move the bishop from c1 if he moves the
bishop he loses this pawn and b2 if he
plays b3 to kick the night he loses the
pawn on c3 so this night although he is
on the edge of the board he is
completely destroying Fischer's Queen
side King to f1 by Fischer and now c5 we
have b3 now he Fischer has to do
something Knight captures and c3b
captures on c5 Fischer does create a
test C pawn but this loses another pawn
Knight captures on e4
we have c6 as the pond was attacked and
now Knight to c5 going for that b3 pawn
also with also with threats of efore
wouldn't attack on the night and the
rook on a1 so Bishop to e3 is played
attacking the knight and c5 we have
night capture some b3r up t2
and eight five and it's well this is
impossible to play for white as calories
up three pawns but Fisher Fisher tries
wrote the g2 again going for Bishop to
h6 acting to h8 and pinning Knight to g5
we have Knight rook to f8 not allowing
the night to go to f7 King to e1 Knight
d4 with a bishop captured son before he
captures on d4 and now Knight to e6 with
the idea well with the idea of tricking
Keller once more as now Fisheries
attacking this g7 Bishop twice with the
rook and the night and he's right he's
inviting Keller to blunder Keller goes
for rook to e8 and it seems like it
seems like Fischer managed to trick him
he plays c7 and what's the idea behind
Fisher's move well it seems like Keller
can capture this night with check and
after the king moves he can play rook to
c6 and then guard guard this point from
Queen but this wouldn't work as if rook
captures on e6 you get rook to e2 and if
you capture the rook now you can't stop
the pond from queening so if you play
something like rope to c6 Bishop has
rook to e8 with check on the movies
Bishop to f8 capturing the bishop with
check King to g7 and now point the c8
with Queen rook captures on c8 rook
captures on c8 and although Keller would
had four pawns for the rook this is
completely winning for Fischer because
the rook will capture all of these pawns
on the Queen side without a problem and
the King will stop this H pawn and then
the rook will simply shift his attention
to the King side and win the game but
after c7 Keller of course it doesn't
fall for this and he plays Bishop to e5
now attacking the seven pawn and well
his Bishop was attacked twice and g7
King to d2 by Fischer and we have worked
the c8 we have rocked the g5 attacking
the bishop and now Bishop captures on c7
and you can't you can't pin the bishop
with rook to c5
so maybe maybe putting the King on a
dark square wasn't that great of an idea
but I thought this would work either way
if you play rock to c5 you'll get bishop
therefore check Keller Keller can
exchange rooks so after Bishop does
captures on c7 or up to b5 capturing
upon by Fischer Bishop to d6 came to d3
we rock to 8 now rook the b6s played
Bishop to g3 rook the b7 and a4 and this
is the moment when you realize that your
opponent is definitely winning the game
is he starts to push his passport Knight
to g5 fisheries threatening to capture
the pawn on e7 but geller knows
sorry Keller knows that this poem
doesn't really have a role to play in
this game
so a3 rook captures on h7 King to g8
rook to h1 we have a to rook the a1 now
this rook is completely passive for the
rest of the game Bishop to e5 at
protecting the d4 pawn 936 rook to a3
with chick King to be for Bishop to f6
came to a5 King to f7 defending the
Bishop Knight to g5 checked by Fischer
and Bishop captures on g5 and in this
position Bobby Fischer resigned the game
because well after for example King
captures Bishop on g5 you get b3 can get
4 and d2 and well the King can come pin
it come any closer but even if he did it
it wouldn't matter can get 5 and now
simply d1 grabbing a record of Queen or
pretty much any piece wins the game rook
captures and now Queen to a 1 upon 2 a1
Queen and this is completely winning so
yeah after this Bishop captures on a
sari after this Bishop captures and g5
fish resigned the game and well in the
end the Fischer did get third place he
was tied for third place with with
vulgaris gligar rich got second place
and Michael towel got sold for
place with eleven and a half points so
it was it was an outstanding performance
by mikhail tal and well
the swiss national champion dieter
keller cost fisher a tied first with
Michael Tao so yeah this is the game I
do hope you enjoyed it as usual you can
check to my previous videos here thank
you for watching and I will see you soon